en el vídeo pasado aprendimos un poquito
acerca de qué se trata un estado de
resultados y vimos un ejemplo para una
compañía muy sencillita que vendía que
vendía artesanías lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es cerrar el ciclo y ver cómo
se relaciona esto con lo que platicamos
en el primer vídeo en términos de precio
por acción después hablaremos de
ganancias por acción en este caso y
también veremos cómo se relaciona el
estado de resultados con la hoja de
balance ya que lo haría en el vídeo
pasado pero se me ha acabado el tiempo
ahora nada más como un pequeño repaso
dijo seguramente acabas de ver el vídeo
pero en caso que no lo hayas hecho
ingresos de ventas literalmente cuánto
venden artesanías digamos en 2008 vendí
3 millones de pesos en artesanías costo
de bienes vendidos se después
simplemente eso el costo de los bienes
vendidos
entonces supongamos que no se hice pues
un millón de artesanías que vendí cada
una de tres pesos entonces para producir
ese millón de artesanías por un peso
cada una me costó un millón de pesos
entonces en total tuve un gasto de
bienes vendidos de un millón de pesos
y luego acá abajo teníamos utilidad neta
que simplemente es cuánto gané por haber
vendido este millón de artesanías y fue
de 2 millones de pesos pero tenía otros
gastos verdad no puedo simplemente
meterlos a mi bolsillo tenía marketing
ventas general y administrativo y
finalmente acabé con un millón de pesos
eso de ahí fue cuánta utilidad operativa
generó mi mi compañía de artesanías va
pero todavía no acabo verdad aprendimos
en el vídeo pasado que pues la compañía
no era totalmente mía tenía un poco de
deuda en este caso 5 millones de pesos
en deuda y tenía que pagar interés era
de 10% anual entonces hay que quitar el
interés nos queda 500 mil pesos de
ingreso antes de impuestos y por
supuesto hay que pagarle al gobierno
podemos debatir si le estamos pagando
mucho o poquito pero sabes me están
dando defensa para que no vengan otros
países a bombardear me no se me están
dando con un poco de suerte una fuerza
laboral bien educada ya sabes caminos
infraestructura electricidad entonces
quién sabe a lo mejor si estoy pagando
lo lo justo finalmente me queda 350 mil
de ingreso neto y cuando las personas
hablan de las ganancias de una compañía
están hablando de esto
ingreso neto el ingreso neto también se
le conoce como ganancias entonces cuando
alguien dice no sea google hizo 4000
millones de dólares este trimestre
pasado trimestres son tres meses verdad
usualmente son en marzo junio septiembre
y diciembre en cada cuarto del año
entonces literalmente están diciendo que
google hizo tres mil millones en ingreso
neto en ingreso neto ahora bueno debido
al pasado cuando hablamos de las
primeras cosas dijimos que las compañías
tienen diferentes números de acciones
vamos a ponerle un número de acciones de
esta compañía
digamos voy a ponerlo aquí en color
morado entonces supongamos que la
compañía tiene a ver acciones que la
cantidad de acciones de esta compañía es
un millón tiene un millón de acciones
millón entonces probablemente has
escuchado no sobre término ganancias
sino también el término ganancias por
acción entonces lo que hace simplemente
es tomar el número de ganancias y lo
divides entre el número de acciones eso
te da la ganancia por acción o gp a
ganancia por acción algunas veces las
personas simplemente dicen gpa no sé la
compañía tuvo un gpa para 2008 en este
caso sería de 350 mil entre un millón
esto cuánto es que 35 centavos entonces
son 35 centavos por acción de gpa
ok entonces a lo mejor bueno de hecho ya
sabes que antes de que me meta con
precio por ganancia y todo eso voy a
hacer la conexión entre la hoja de
balance y el estado de resultados que ya
te lo prometí desde el vídeo pasado
entonces en este periodo gane 350 mil
pesos toda la forma en la cual podemos
pensar a un estado de resultados es que
nos dice qué sucede entre dos
fotografías que nos dan unas hojas de
balance no se deja de poner una fecha
que supongamos que el 31 de diciembre de
2007 la hoja de balance para la compañía
se veía más o menos así déjame dibujarla
nada más no voy a usar la herramienta al
cuadrado lo voy a hacer así más como
dicen a mano alzada entonces tiene 10
millones de pesos en activo activo
digamos que tenía 5 millones de pesos en
deuda 5 millones esto de aquí lo podemos
pensar como el pasivo usualmente la
deuda nada más es un pasivo pero ahí
está digamos que es todo son 5 millones
en pasivo de modo que el capital de los
accionistas o mejor dicho el valor en
libro del capital de la compañía es de 5
millones
5 millones en capital
en capital y nada más para amarrar un
poquito lo que hicimos lo que hicimos en
el primer vídeo si tenemos un millón de
acciones entonces el valor en libro por
acción pues el valor el libro del
capital total es de 5 millones pero el
valor en libro por acción va a ser este
número dividido entre la cantidad de
acciones entre el millón de acciones que
tenemos 5 millones en 3 millones 5 pesos
entonces este de acá es el valor el
libro recuerda que hay una diferencia
entre valor el libro y el valor de
mercado y después vamos a hablar un poco
más de esto verdad el precio de esta
acción podría ser distinto podría ser 10
7 o un peso extra y sería el valor del
mercado pero estoy aquí es el valor en
libros el valor en libros simplemente
está diciendo buena tomamos el valor el
libro de los activos esto lo platicamos
un poquito en el vídeo pasado dijimos
pagamos 10 millones por eso entonces hay
esa cantidad de valor después nos vamos
a meter en detalles de cómo evaluar esto
pero hay que quitarle el pasivo nos
queda cinco millones verdad de acuerdo
con los contadores el valor en mercado
puede ser muy diferente pero bueno
ahorita no me quiero meter mucho
pero ahora supongamos que el 2008 sucede
si pasa todo el 2008
ok entonces todo 2008 sucede y llegamos
al primero de enero de 2009 bueno puedes
decir 31 de diciembre de 2008 no importa
igual es un día feriado verdad un día
más un día menos
pero entonces tenemos una nueva hoja de
balance y vamos a ver qué pasó en el año
a ver en el transcurso del año ganamos
un poco de dinero y no me quiero
complicar mucho con el efectivo y con la
contabilidad devengada ahorita entonces
vamos a decir que ahorita nada más así
para entender que está sucediendo que
esos 350 mil que ganamos si realmente lo
ganamos entonces tenemos 350 mil en
ganancias de modo que nuestro activo
aumentó entre 150 mil pesos
digo pudo haber aumentado en 350.000
efectivos popular haber aumentado entre
150 mil en pagarés por ejemplo en deudas
por cobrar esto y después voy a hacer un
vídeo no una serie de vídeos en cuentas
por cobrar sobre estar padre pero
básicamente es un activo que dice que
alguien me debe dinero pero de cualquier
forma nuestro activo va a haber
aumentado por esta cantidad de acá va
pues en el transcurso del año aumentó y
nuestra nueva hoja de balance al final
de 2008 o sea ya pasó todo 2008 déjame
dibujar por aquí 2008 2008 a cabo al fin
al final del 2008 nuestro activo se
vería un poco más alto verdad algo de
este estilo porque ahora valdría 10
millones 350 mil pesos
voy a poner así 10 350.000 entonces son
diez mil trescientos cincuenta mil es
social 10.35 millones va ok y vamos a
ver a ver lo único que hicimos fue pagar
el interés de la deuda en este ejemplo
verdad nomás pagamos el interés y para
que lo sepas o sea la deuda corporativa
usualmente sucede así cada año se paga
nada más los intereses pero no se paga
el principal eso es distinto y con lo
que pasa con las hipotecas verdad
entonces todavía tenemos la misma
cantidad de deuda no hemos pagado nada
de la de la deuda principal entonces
todavía tenemos 5 millones en deuda
entonces qué pasa con el capital pues
bueno todas nuestras ganancias como la
deuda quedó igual todas las ganancias
van directo al capital entonces
tendríamos cinco millones trescientos
cincuenta mil pesos en capital
muy bien entonces la forma en la cual yo
lo pienso y en la cual te recomiendo que
lo pienses es que las ganancias de una
compañía para las ganancias de una
compañía en este caso los 350 mil pesos
para este año o los puntos 35 centavos
por acción
esencialmente te dicen que sucedió de
una de hoja de balance a la otra
entonces aquí te dice que este número
verdad sea la cantidad en la cual creció
el capital justo es justo es las
ganancias 350 mil pesos en ganancias
ganancias
trescientos cincuenta mil pesos en
ganancias y hay algo que quiero platicar
tantito porque en el vídeo pasado hablé
un poco acerca del retorno sobre activo
donde tomábamos la utilidad operativa
deberíamos entre la cantidad de activo y
nos daba un retorno de 10% y podrías
preguntarme por qué no creció el activo
en 10% y la razón es porque pues tuvimos
que pagar algo de impuestos verdad
incluso aunque no tuviéramos deuda
tendríamos que pagar impuestos este
renglón desaparecería pero algunas veces
cuando las personas hablan de retorno
sobre la inversión como lo hice en el
vídeo pasado pues es bueno que aclaren
si hablan del retorno antes o después de
impuestos en el ejemplo del vídeo pasado
fue el retorno sobre activos antes de
impuestos pero bueno esta conexión es
interesante verdad las hojas de balance
simplemente son fotografías son como
pues tu cuenta bancaria cuánto vales en
cada momento mientras que el estado de
resultados te dice cómo llegaste de una
hoja a la otra
muy bien vamos a aprender después que el
estado de flujo de efectivo también se
reconcilia con estos dos pues nos dice
que le sucede a la cuenta de efectivo en
la hoja de balance y detalle un poco más
las operaciones del estado de resultados
vamos a hacer esto después pero bueno
empezamos hablando en este vídeo de que
es barato que es caro entonces la
pregunta es cómo puedes determinar si no
puedes simplemente pues fijarte en el
precio a ver espera creo que mi gato me
está pidiendo comida voy a checar eso
igual ya me pase de los 10 minutos nos
vemos en el próximo vídeo